Ну що друзі Кінець епохи кумавства
настав Вітаю всіх вас Дивіться якщо в
житті так сталося що ви є сусідами
родини зеленських то вас далі в житті
буде все добре От питають мене Чому саме
піщанська чому вона я скажу вам Ну
напевно Може ви б стали президентом ви б
своїх сусідів призначали а став
Володимир Олександрович Він призначає
своїх До речі з нами є сьогодні Ольга
піщанська Може вона в своєму виступі
пояснить Це дуже цікаво дивіться її
сестра Світлана піщанська директорка
фірми на яку оформлена Віла родини
зеленських в Італії Ну я все розумію ну
ви вже були головою антимонопольного
комітету тепер голова рахункової палати
ну незамінна людина ну Може все-таки
пошукати серед інших сусідів Ну не можеш
впертися в одну сусідку в одну родину це
якось Мені здається навіть І незрозуміло
інші сусіди можуть і образитись все-таки
теж жили десь поруч А ви якось їх весь
час обходите друзі це треба припиняти цю
дурню це дурня це рахункова палата
України це палата Яка має
рахувати наші гроші ваші гроші тих хто
зараз нас дивляться а ще гроші отих
людей оцим папірце прапорцем
Європейського союзу з прапором
Сполучених Штатів Америки вони хочуть
знати як порахують гроші а в нас будь
ласочка в нас є людина вона відпрацювала
своє в антимонопольному тепер вам
порахує гроші все нормально так не має
бути це ніхто в світі не зрозуміє Я
розумію що Президент говорить на
прес-конференції є в мене 4чотири-5ть
менеджерів то ми тепер розуміємо це
4чотири-5ять сусідів чи 4чотири-5ять
друзів і вони будуть по шахматки ходить
сьогодні один завтра інший може вони в
лотерею де переходять з посади на посаду
друзі це треба припиняти